- [Narrator:] There's a singular moment,
something most people will never realize,
where all your efforts
culminate to deliver your dream,
where you realize your purpose.
For Cole Anthony, that was now,
back home in NYC and
ready for the NBA draft.
But it wasn't that simple.
[A collage of different news reporters' voices begins]
- In just this hour...
- Chinese authorities have
traced a new deadly virus back
to the city of Wuhan.
- The symptoms include fever,
difficulty breathing.
- The first coronavirus
death confirmed in the U.S.
- The number of coronavirus cases jumped
by nearly 5,000 here in the United States.
- This has been quick,
fierce, fast and ferocious.
- We have never seen
anything like this before.
- [Cole Anthony:] I was never expecting
it to get to this level.
I thought they would have
had it under control by now.
But it's really just gotten
out of hand, which is crazy.
- [Donald Trump:] I'm officially
declaring a national emergency.
[A collage of different news reporters' voices begins]
- The coronavirus crisis
is changing so fast.
The great shutdown of 2020 is underway.
- More than three-quarters of Americans
are under stay-at-home orders tonight.
- [Cole Anthony:] Just being in New York,
being at the center of all this madness,
I've seen that it's a lot of
people suffering right now.
I haven't really had
that experience in New York,
cuz they have everything shut down.
- [Casey Stern:] There are probably a lot of things that,
and as a dad, G.A., with your experience,
you think about basketball and his life,
no one's ever been through
what we're all going through.
What have conversations been
like between the two of you?
- Just me and my dad have
been pretty much talking
once every couple days.
You know, there's been a few times
where he hadn't reached
out to me for a while
[Greg Anthony laughing]
and I had to pretty
much reach my hand out
and try to make sure he was still alive.
Just the fact that this is something
that a lot of people
can go several lifetimes
without ever enduring,
it's really crazy.
[A collage of different news reporters' voices begins]
- The entire sports world
just come to a complete halt.
- It must be crushing to
some of the players.
- Reports are that the NBA likely
will be pushing back the
start date of the NBA draft.
- [Cole Anthony:] Due to corona,
I don't really think it's changed my path.
I don't think it's changed much
just in terms of my basketball.
I think it's just really
given me the opportunity
to just be laser-focused,
just to really focus on what matters
at this point in my life,
which is basketball.
- [Trainer:] Nice. Good work.
One, two, switch those feet, pull up.
Way to shoot. Way to shoot.
- A normal day in New York...
I got into a pretty
comfortable routine.
They closed the gym that I go to,
but they're letting us
get special access after hours.
I mean, I've pretty much changed my whole schedule
just so that I can get in the gym at night.
And then rest and repeat.
Same thing, every day.
- [Trainer:] Stay with it.
You're all right. Let's go.
Get downhill. Get
downhill. Get to the rim.
- [Cole Anthony:] I've been really in
there with these workouts.
And whenever I get into the
gym, I go super hard.
Going 120 percent whenever I get in.
So I don't think I'm
gonna fall off too hard
just from getting out of game-shape.
- [Trainer:] Kick, kick.
Let's go. Get up. Get up.
- To me, I think a lot of people
are gonna use this as an excuse
to pretty much stop playing basketball,
just stop working, stop working hard.
And I just, I don't look for excuses.
I look for just every advantage I can get.
Try to stay ahead of the pack.
- [Trainer:] Put it down hard.
- [Narrator:] With nothing
to do and nowhere to go,
Cole only had one mindset: grind.
Despite everything going on in the world,
Cole took this chance to
get out of the spotlight
and just work.
- [Jonathan Wasserman:] I don't think the coronavirus is going
to affect Cole Anthony's draft stock.
People are gonna forget
that North Carolina
wasn't gonna make the NCAA tournament
because nobody's gonna know
who was actually supposed to
get to the NCAA tournament.
- [Franklyn Calle:] I think, in general,
it's been a very weird
college basketball season, right?
You had a lot of the top
players who weren't even playing.
LaMelo Ball wasn't playing in college.
RJ Hampton wasn't playing in college.
James Wiseman barely played in college.
Cole Anthony was battling injuries.
So a lot of the big names
weren't really even
playing college basketball.
I'm very curious, if you're an NBA scout,
based on whatever happened this season,
how do you even evaluate all of this?
[A collage of different analysts' voices begins]
- Cole Anthony came in with as much hype
as you could possibly
come in with to college.
- He was, I think, NBA-ready
when he was a junior in high school.
- Perplexing freshman
season to say the least.
-  Whenever you have a
really explosive player
and they have a knee injury,
it does take a hit on their draft stock.
- I would be able to overlook
that North Carolina season.
- Cole is someone who, at every stage,
has been able to go through
some bumps and bruises
and then excel.
- He came in with a lot
of hype, Cole Anthony did.
Unfortunately with the knee injury,
his season was cut short.
- His whole year was incomplete
because he had the injury.
Then he had a team that really struggled.
He wasn't able to really
fulfill those expectations.
- He was gonna be a top-10 pick
regardless. The pieces around
him just weren't good enough
to show how good of a point guard
I believe this young man could truly be.
- I think a lot of, like, kids
just have not dealt
with adversity to this level.
A lot of kids are just
used to it going their way,
used to winning the
majority of their games.
Really haven't dealt with losing seasons,
haven't dealt with just the struggles,
the hardships of a season like that.
So I think all it could do
is benefit me in the future.
- Big picture with Cole Anthony,
I mean, he still averaged 20
points a game this year,
and 6'3", athletic.
And again, you're projecting
long-term potential.
I don't think teams put too
much stock into what happens
during a 20-, 30-game
sample size in college.
- [Narrator:] The uncertainty
had been crushing.
Draft on hold. Quarantine.
Midnight workouts.
No clarity on the future.
And finally it was announced:
NBA draft was slated for November 18th.
Next step in Cole's journey has arrived.
- [Cole Anthony:] I just think that, to whatever team
wants to take a chance on me,
I just think you'll get
someone who's gonna work
as hard as they can every single day,
not gonna make excuses,
just gonna get in there, work,
try to make everyone around them better.
I promise they will
not regret drafting me.
- [Interviewer:] There's
rumors that, you know, the Knicks
might be involved.
Would you like to go to the
Knicks cuz of New York?
- I mean, look, hey, it would be cool.
I mean, I'd be blessed up to be
drafted to any team, though.
So whatever team that is, I'm just,
I'll be very thankful
and grateful to them,
and I'll give them everything I can.
- Knick posters!
- [Wassman:] I think Cole Anthony to the Knicks
would kind of bring back
some of that '90s love
that everybody had for the Knicks.
- [Announcer on footage:] Ewing! Oh, ho! Wow!
- [Calle:] I think the city would get behind him
because he's one of us.
He's a New York product.
Because he grew up here.
He's absolutely not afraid of the life.
- [Wasserman:] You want a guy who really wants to win
and is the type of guy who
can put a team on his back.
And that's Cole Anthony.
And he loves the moment.
He loves the bright lights.
I think that's...he's perfectly
suited for New York.
- I truly haven't thought
about just having a legacy
just in New York.
I just, I've thought bigger than that.
I don't want to just be having
that legacy in New York.
I wanna have a legacy
that goes throughout the world.
In the NBA, there are
those perennial All-Stars.
There are those dudes who
are at the top of the league.
And I just, I see myself
in that elite category.
I mean, people might knock me for that.
That's where I see myself,
and I'm going to hold
myself to that level.
- [Narrator:] Cole came up a prodigal son
in New York's crowded basketball scene.
Whether you believe he's
the next great point guard
from the big city or not,
nobody can deny this kid's hunger.
♪♪♪ Gave my life to the game ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Had my mama concerned ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ It made her calm when she saw ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ What I got in return ♪♪♪
- [Narrator:] Dude wants to be a legend,
not in the shadow of his
pops, but in his own right.
♪♪♪ Said I'mma be a legend soon ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I'm a legend now ♪♪♪
- [Greg Anthony:] I was a stereotypical kid from the hood.
And the game was gonna be my way
to do things in life that ordinarily
wouldn't be accomplished by people
that grew up like me, living where I lived,
which is completely different for my son.
♪♪♪ I'm like Ali, I fight better ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ With my back on the ropes ♪♪♪
- [Calle:] He is as intense as he is
not because of some necessity reason.
This dude really wants to
be really good at his craft.
Money isn't driving it, you know,
and I think that's the scary part of this.
♪♪♪ Checks overgrown ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Neck boulder stones ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Ever since they said I'm going pro ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ They said I'm the next so-and-so ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ But you know how it go ♪♪♪
- [Roy Williams:] My favorite part of
Cole's game is very easily
is he loves to play basketball.
When I say loves, I mean
with a capital L-O-V-E-S,
all of them capitalized, bold print.
Basketball is his deal.
It's the real deal with him.
♪♪♪ Broke my flow down ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ They still can't describe it in words ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ And all the work they say they put in ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I gotta confirm ♪♪♪
- [Greg Anthony:] He's got a purity and a passion
just for the love of the game.
The truly greats in our game
have always loved the game.
They don't fall in love with the life.
They fall in love and
stay in love with the game.
- I don't want to just make it
to the NBA just to say I made it.
♪♪♪ Just so happens had a hunger for greatness, and I fed it ♪♪♪
That's one thing that my dad tells me,
that he had that regret.
He didn't want to be great.
My ultimate goal at basketball is
to be one of the best that ever played.
♪♪♪ Said I'mma be a legend soon ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I'm a legend now ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ They tried to tell me ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I'mma be a legend soon, though ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ But I'm a legend now ♪♪♪